buenas noches y muchísimas gracias por
la oportunidad
hoy les voy a plantear una pregunta que
me vengo haciendo desde hace algunos
años y que la voy a desarrollar durante
esta charla a través de tres
experiencias la pregunta es cuál es
aquel ingrediente que todos y todas
nosotros necesitamos para transformar
nuestro entorno de manera positiva es
una pregunta que estuve recientemente
discutiendo con alicia y con beatriz son
nombres protegidos de estos dos jóvenes
que
se reunieron conmigo en la plaza de su
comunidad una tarde para hablar acerca
de los desafíos que enfrentan el lugar
en donde ellas viven los sueños que
tienen y recordar un poco hace seis años
cómo fue ese proyecto que juntos
estuvimos emprendiendo en su escuela en
ese momento ya tenían 66 perdón 9 y 13
años de edad ya habían crecido y todavía
tenían algunas reflexiones al respecto
lo primero que hicimos fue definir
juntos que era la autoconfianza me
interesaba muchísimo conocer desde su
perspectiva que era y llegaron a tres
definiciones propias la primera era que
estoy seguro de que voy a llegar a mi
meta la segunda era estoy seguro de que
voy a llegar y que nadie me va a frenar
y la tercera en creer que puedo esas
tres cosas y esas tres ideas formaron
las primeras definiciones de auto
confianza para ellas
y era importante porque el desafío que
tenían no era nada menor vivían en un
contexto y en un colegio en donde
cualquier persona que levantaba la mano
y tenía alguna idea como para proponer
algo que representara trabajo adicional
quizás no la iba a pasar muy bien pero
de todas maneras se atrevieron antes que
nada quiero decirles que tenían dos
miedos importantes el primero justo eso
que se enfrentarse al bullying y
enfrentarse al criticismo ya la iv a los
cuestionamientos de sus compañeros del
curso y la segunda que está me impactó
muchísimo
que los adultos les vieran como
demasiado pequeñas como que no podían
desarrollar un proyecto que realmente
transformará su comunidad esto fue lo
que pasó lo que hicieron primero es
hacer una encuesta a 85 estudiantes de
su escuela
hombres y mujeres
les plantearon algunas preguntas creo
que la más importante si es que les
gustaba o les interesaba leer la mayoría
dijo que si esto era alentador pero el
otro lado habían otros desafíos por
ejemplo padres y madres de familia de
los encuestados no tenían en la casa el
hábito de la lectura y empezaron a
cuestionarse pero de todas maneras
siguieron adelante llevaron libros de su
clase materiales didácticos de esferos
marcadores de todo frente a la cancha de
fútbol y empezaron a traer a muchísimos
otros estudiantes que se interesaron en
la iniciativa mis estudiantes de
bachillerato aunque un poco escépticos
al inicio pero también muy curiosos como
que estaban pendientes de qué era lo que
estaba sucediendo y algunos se anotaban
en la lista de préstamos sólo haber
reunido inmovilizado a tantos
estudiantes generó de alguna manera un
impacto en ellas y les ayudó a seguir
motivando a más estudiantes esto duró
más o menos unos dos meses y antes de
que termine el proyecto y el sueño
asistieron a una feria educativa en
donde la presentaron frente a otras
decenas de estudiantes presentaron el
resultado del proyecto y además los
hallazgos de la encuesta
rompieron finalmente ese paradigma de
que no hace falta ser un adulto y no
hace falta ser grande para realmente ser
grande y transformar el entorno en el
que vivimos
en un colegio al otro extremo de la
ciudad ocurrió algo parecido desafíos
parecidos como cuestionamiento si es que
tienes una idea o un sueño con el que
quieres trabajar en este caso restaurar
un espacio en el colegio para volverlo
un lugar de descanso de relajación y
para servirnos los alimentos porque en
la cancha de fútbol los balones volaban
tan rápida y violentamente que a veces
les tumbaba en la comida sobre todo las
chicas dos chicas brillantes las
movilizadoras de este proyecto lideraron
esta iniciativa y no eran las únicas
varios otros grupos estaban haciendo lo
mismo en otros colegios y frecuentemente
se reunían a dialogar sobre sus
experiencias para aprender para jugar y
sobre todo para recibir apoyo y mantener
su motivación alta a través de un
voluntario un mentor o una mentora que
les ayudaba en las gestiones en el
colegio y afuera
estas reuniones tuvieron un impacto bien
interesante en ellos porque en ellos y
en ellas porque existe un soporte
emocional y social que tienen los
adolescentes porque se apoyan mucho
entre ellos dialogan y confían además
generar este tipo de proyectos en ellos
desarrolla mentalidades y capacidades
que son importantísimas en su transición
hacia la adultez y si es que estas
contribuciones o proyectos son valorados
por los demás por las autoridades del
colegio por otros compañeros el
compromiso puede incrementarse y es
importante tomar esto en cuenta porque
la salud mental de los adolescentes hoy
en día es un desafío global muy muy muy
alarmante países de renta baja y media
enfrentan en la cifra de 15 por ciento
de adolescentes que han considerado
suicidarse y aquí en ecuador la cifra no
es tampoco tan alentadora es la segunda
causa de mortalidad entre jóvenes entre
12 y 17 años fallecen más jóvenes aquí
en ecuador por suicidio que por
accidentes de tránsito
estas experiencias de reunirlos les
generan una un sostenga emocional como
lo mencioné y además les ayuda a
desarrollar otras habilidades confían
más en que su inteligencia puede crecer
y cambiar en que pueden perseverar en
tener los desafíos en que tienen una red
de apoyo en quienes pueden confiar
también en que pueden levantar fondos
donaciones con empresas locales y que
pueden convencer a otros estudiantes
también de juntarse movilizaron a padres
y madres de familia que acomodaron la
chatarra y que luego del primer día de
jornada generaban un espacio muchísimo
mejor de lo que había comenzado con
plantas medicinales y con sobre todo ese
entusiasmo de que en verdad un pequeño
grupo puede generar una movilización
importante
y la última historia que es la de
rebekah una joven indígena que vive
también aquí en la ciudad de quito que
desea tener desafíos externos el
principal desafío que tenía era uno
interno desde pequeña desarrolló una
discapacidad auditiva que le frustraba
porque sufría discriminación de algunos
de sus compañeros de clase y además le
frustraba recibir exámenes que eran
adaptados curricularmente más sencillos
de los que ella realmente podría
resolver y
y realmente no se sentía muy bien se
sentía molesta su hermana durante años
fue su apoyo y le incentivo sobre todo
no dejar el colegio y a buscar otro tipo
de estrategias para afrontar este
malestar la primera estrategia creo que
fue definitiva fue un día rebeca se
soltó el pelo y tapó el audífono que
durante años le había molestado empezó a
vivir ya convivir con la discapacidad a
partir de ese día de mejor manera y al
principio del año lectivo nadie tenía
que enterarse sobre eso su hermana
también le motivó a unirse a un grupo de
jóvenes mujeres jóvenes mujeres que se
reunían para hablar sobre los derechos
de las niñas y de las jóvenes mujeres
para capacitarse y sobre todo para alzar
la voz a favor de la igualdad de género
en este espacio rebeca encontró
creo que todas cosas muy importantes un
lugar en donde su opinión realmente
valía la pena y donde equivocarse no
estaba mal era un espacio seguro en
donde su voz se hacía escuchar y del
otro lado otras jóvenes que tenían una
lucha interna o una lucha externa
importante por la que en verdad estaban
apasionadas y que a ellas le hicieron
reconocer la suya propia generar una
nueva perspectiva alrededor de la
discapacidad y hacer que las personas
piensen diferente al respecto desde una
desde un punto de vista muchísimo más
inclusivo dentro de este espacio su voz
se volvió cada vez más fuerte y postuló
a través de un vídeo contando sus
experiencias y sus motivaciones a la
conferencia de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos más grande del mundo que
se desarrolló en mexico
ella participó en el campamento juvenil
era la adolescente más joven de todo ese
grupo y ese espíritu de resiliencia se
hizo notar entonces le escogieron para
que sea la vocera de todas las
de todas las necesidades y de todas las
aspiraciones de los jóvenes de
latinoamérica que se presentaron frente
a cientos de personas organizaciones
gobierno y organismos internacionales
y este y esta oportunidad luego la llevó
a otra conferencia también la de
población y desarrollo en nairobi en
donde habló frente a otros cientos de
personas
creo que lo que más recuerda a ella no
es tanto lo fluido que salió su discurso
ni lo poderoso de su argumento sino que
finalmente había tenido varias
experiencias y oportunidades para ir
aceptando
y esa lucha que tenía y volverla a un
motivo de inspiración para otras porque
se había vuelto una vocera
de jóvenes de toda la región
algo en lo con lo que quisiera concluir
es tenemos varias personas que se
encuentran en el centro y que tienen un
sueño hacia el cual quieren llegar que
es muy fuerte sin embargo enfrentan
varios desafíos en el camino que pueden
disminuir la auto confianza que puedan
que ellos podrían tener la autonegación
bullying miedo o el propio boicot a
veces de ellos mismos y de otros sin
embargo hay otros elementos que son
importantes y que debemos prestarles
atención que pueden ayudar a que todos
estos desafíos cada vez se vuelvan más
pequeños y vayan desapareciendo el apoyo
de familia y de amigos colaboración con
otros incluso si es que al principio no
están de acuerdo tener espacios seguros
en donde poder poder hacer que nuestra
voz se haga escuchar recibir
oportunidades para hacer que esa voz
crezca que provienen de los docentes y
de nuestros de nuestros mentores generar
o apoyarse de una radio de un movimiento
que nos hace cada vez mejores que nos
desafía y que nos impulsa
y con quienes nos identificamos mucho y
qué suerte si es que se puede reconocer
ese aporte porque es un incentivo para
cada vez hacernos alimentar esa
auto-confianza que necesitamos una
pregunta con la que me voy es qué
pasaría si es que pudiéramos generar
cada vez más de estas oportunidades y
combinar todos estos elementos en una
experiencia para que muchos
muchos de muchos más jóvenes puedan ir
alimentando esa auto-confianza para
transformar sus entornos quedémonos con
esa pregunta también nosotros y que nos
hace falta para transformar los nuestros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]